maría tiene un poste rectangular de 36
pulgadas x 20 pulgadas el poste
rectangular de susana es de 26 pulgadas
x 30 pulgadas cual póster tiene un área
mayor y por cuántas pulgadas cuadradas
analicemos esto aquí tenemos el póster
de maría que tiene 36 pulgadas x 20
pulgadas 36 pulgadas de largo por 20
pulgadas de ancho sería algo así un
póster rectangular así es que el área
del póster de maría es 36 x 20 y esto a
cuánto es igual 36 x 272 el 6 que 36 x
20 serían 720 pulgadas cuadradas
pulgadas cuadradas ahora veamos el
póster de susana el póster de susana que
tiene unas dimensiones de 26 x 30 tiene
26 de ancho por 30 de largo déjame hacer
bien el rectángulo algo así algo así
sería podemos determinar entonces que el
área el área del póster de susana es de
26 x 30 pulgadas cuadradas y esto es
igual a hagamos por acá la
multiplicación 26 por 30 es igual de
hecho 11 el 26 por 3 y luego agregamos
el 0
esto sería entonces 3 por 6 18 llevamos
13 por 26 y 17 esto nos da 78 de hecho
esto lo podría haber hecho mentalmente 3
por 20 60 3 por 6 18 sumando da 78 pero
como estamos multiplicando por 30 hay
que agregarle un 0 así es que es 780 el
área del póster de susana es 780
pulgadas cuadradas ahora la pregunta
cuál póster tiene un área mayor el de
susana el de susana y por cuántas
pulgadas cuadradas el póster de susana
tiene 780 pulgadas cuadradas el de maria
720 pulgadas cuadradas así es que por 60
pulgadas cuadradas 780 menos 720 es 60